Imagine just for a second that you are asked to grade your own job performance.
Okay. Sounds like standard HR stuff, right?
Right. But instead of sitting down with a rubric and doing it yourself, you have your AI assistant do it. Like it reads through all your Slack messages, scans every internal document you've touched this month, and it writes the review for you.
Honestly, that sounds kind of amazing.
It does. But then here's the real kicker. You take that AI-generated review and you publish it as rock-solid proof to the government that your company is behaving responsibly.
Yeah, that sounds like a wild corporate thought experiment.
It does. But that dynamic is exactly the reality we need to unpack today. Welcome to this deep dive. If you're listening to this and thinking, well, my company's self-evaluations are already a joke, you're going to want to hear this.
Because Anthropic just dropped a bombshell report.
Right. On September 17th, 2026, the Anthropic Institute published this document. It's called Measurements for Understanding the Pace of AI Development Inside Frontier Labs.
And they are claiming that their AI is basically managing a massive chunk of their own research.
Exactly. And the core tension we're exploring today is not some sci-fi intelligence explosion, you know, where machines take over. It is entirely about measurement and trust.
Which is a huge deal.
We have a frontier lab using its own models to grade how much of its own work those models are doing. And they're asking the public to treat this as a serious governance instrument.
It's a massive paradigm shift in how we monitor artificial intelligence. I mean, truly.
But we aren't just going to take their numbers at face value, right?
No, definitely not. To figure out if this anthropic R&D automation index actually holds water, we're pulling in five crucial background studies today.
You've got a great stack of sources.
Yeah, we'll look at research from Epoch AI to understand the baseline, an adversarial framework called RBench, a randomized controlled trial on developer productivity, the Foundation Model Transparency Index, and some deep research on how we monitor an AI's
internal thoughts.
Basically, we're putting Anthropix's internal claims under a massive external microscope. Because look, if a bank audited itself and proudly announced to the world, hey, we're 99% compliant with regulations, we'd all demand to see the
receipts.
Right. Why should an AI company be any different?
Exactly. So before we get to the staggering automation number Anthropic published, I want to understand the foundation here. Why go through the trouble of building a massive internal measurement system? Like, don't we already have standard tests and benchmarks for
AI?
We do, yeah, but those standard benchmarks have a fatal flaw. Okay. To understand why, we really have to look at a foundational paper from APOC AI. This is by researchers Dinane, Kwan, and Ho, and it's called Toward an O-Net for AI R&D.
Okay, and what's their main argument?
Well, they argue that the AI industry has been suffering from this phenomenon called street lighting.
Street lighting. I've actually heard that term used in economics. It's that old joke about the guy looking for his lost keys under the street lamp just because the light is better there.
Even though he dropped them in the dark alley. Exactly. That's the perfect analogy. Right. So in the AI world, street lighting means extrapolating progress based on things that are just simply easy to measure.
Like what?
Like looking at raw compute proxies or, you know, using METR time horizons, which basically means we test an AI on isolated short term coding puzzles.
Oh, I see. Because it's easy to greet a 10 minute coding puzzle.
Exactly. But that totally ignores the reality of actual AI research workflows. I mean, solving a sterile puzzle in 10 minutes does not mean an AI can manage a messy, ambiguous like. six-month software project.
Right, dealing with legacy code and confused human coworkers.
Yeah, exactly. So Epoch AI proposed a different solution. They said, we need to break down AI R&D into a highly granular taxonomy of specific tasks.
Modeled after the ONET database.
Yes.
Let me just pause you there, because not everyone listening is an HR specialist. The ONED database is the Department of Labor system, right? That's right. It maps out thousands of human jobs into measurable skills, like a carpenter needs X amount of spatial reasoning and Y amount of arm strength.
Precisely. So APOC AI wanted to build that exact kind of database, but for AI research tasks. And to measure the AI's capability on those tasks, they created an automation scale.
And how does that scale work?
It runs from AL0, which is zero AI involvement, all the way up to AL5, which is full unsupervised economy. Okay. But for our discussion today, the two critical levels are AL3, where the AI collaborates under human direction, and
AL4.
AL4 is where it actually leaves the task, right?
Yes, AL4 is where the AI leads from a high-level prompt and the human just kind of steps back and supervises.
Okay, so APOC AI basically said, hey, we need a flashlight to look in the bushes where the actual messy R&D work happens. We can't just look under the street lamp of easy benchmark.
Exactly.
And Anthropic took that APOC framework and basically built their own flashlight. And the number they found in the bushes
is
wild.
It really is.
Using this framework, Anthropic claims that as of August 2026, their AI, Claude, leads, meaning it hits that AL4 level on 26% of Anthropic's own AI R&D work.
Yeah, that 26% figure is the headline for a reason. Because if you look at the timeline, that number was under 1% just in February of 2026. Wait,
in six months it jumped from under 1% to 26%? Yeah.
And they also report that over 90% of their R&D work is at or above the AL3 collaborates level.
Wow. But they did say 0% is at full AL5 autonomy.
Right. Absolutely. 0% is fully autonomous. But still, having an AI act as the lead engineer on a quarter of the work required to build the next generation of AI is a monumental claim.
It's massive, which means we really have to rigorously unpack their methodology. Like, how did they actually arrive at 26%?
Because the method is the real story here. The AI basically built the index about itself.
Let's walk through these mechanics step by step, because honestly, it feels a bit like a hall of mirrors. First, Anthropic had a Claude research agent sample 20% of the staff across their R&D departments.
And this was every single week in July 2026.
Right. And this Claude agent actually read their human Slack messages and internal documentation to extract exactly what those humans were doing.
Yeah. And that initial extraction generated roughly 15,000 granular tasks.
But you can't analyze 15,000 chaotic text descriptions.
No. So Claude had to organize them. It structured those tasks into what Anthropic calls a frozen tree of 542 nodes. OK,
stop there. What is a frozen tree with nodes actually mean in plain English for someone trying to picture this?
Sure. So think of the tree as a massive corporate org chart, but for tasks instead of people.
OK.
The trunk is building AI. The major branches are departments like testing or safety. And as you move further out on the branches, you get to the leaves.
So out of those 542 nodes, 378 are leaf nodes, right? Exactly.
A leaf node is a hyper-specific, indivisible task. Anthropy gives the example of evil platform defect diagnosis and fixes.
Which translates to what?
Basically, an engineer trying to figure out why the software used for testing the AI just crashed and then writing the code to fix it.
Got it. So Claude reads the Slack chats, builds this massive tree of 378 specific leaf nodes, and then what happens?
Then another Claude research agent gathers evidence for each of those nodes from the company's internal systems. And finally, an independent Claude judge looks at that evidence and assigns the Epoch AL0 to AL5 rating to the task.
And how are these ratings weighted?
They're weighted by person time. This is crucial. They aren't weighted by a subjective management opinion of what is important. The index measures how much actual human time is spent on that specific node.
I have a really hard time swallowing this whole process. Claude reads the employee slacks, organizes the task tree, gathers the evidence, and then a different instance of Claude steps in as the judge to evaluate the evidence and see how good Claude is at its job. I mean, it's
literally an employee writing their own performance review, having their digital clone approve it, and then handing it to the human boss.
It does sound like that, yeah.
So how often did the human bosses actually agree with this AI judge?
Well, we have to look at the validation numbers, and they are pretty sobering. Model versus human exact agreement, meaning the human evaluator agreed exactly with the AI's AL rating, was only 59%.
59%. I mean, if I hand a regulator a compliance report that is only 59% accurate to human judgment, I'm getting shut down.
It sounds abysmal on its face, I agree, but the context here is critical because the human versus human agreement was actually even worse.
Wait, really?
Yeah. When two humans tried to grade the same tasks, they only agreed 35% of the time.
Unpack that for me. Why are humans so terrible at grading their own work?
Because R&D is inherently ambiguous. I mean, where is the line between AL3 collaborating and AL4 leading?
That's a fair point.
Right. If you prompt an AI to write a script and it writes 80% of it, but then you have to spend an hour fixing a structural logic error, did the AI lead that task or did it just
collaborate? So two humans will just give you two different answers.
Exactly. And to be fair to Anthropic's system, the model and the human evaluators were within one AL level of each other 97% of the time.
So the broad strokes align, even if the exact borders are blurry.
Yes.
I see the logic, but I'm still seeing a massive blind spot here. And Anthropic actually admits to this in their own appendix. It's the frozen basket problem.
Right. This is a big one.
If the baseline tree of tasks is frozen in July 2026, the index is only measuring the automation of those specific tasks.
Precisely.
What if the AI speeds up the coding, but humans are now spending all their time doing completely new types of high-level systems architecture? It's like measuring how much of a horse carriage driver's job has been automated by cars, but completely ignoring that the human is now
operating a forklift.
Yeah. The frozen basket problem means the index might be structurally overstating the feeling of job displacement. It measures the automation of the past, not the creation of the future.
But let me push back on the very foundation of this data. We established that Anthropix Index is built on what their records, specifically human Slack messages, say happened. But
what if the humans are just wrong about how helpful the AI is? We have a study in our stack that challenges this directly.
You're referring to the randomized controlled trial by Becker, Rush, Barnes, and Rain.
Yes. This
is easily the sharpest challenge to Anthropic's entire methodology.
Walk us through what Becker and his team actually did because it fundamentally questions human perception.
So the Becker team took highly experienced open source software developers and they tested their productivity on real world tasks with and without AI assistance.
Okay. And what did they find?
The psychological finding was fascinating. The developers actively believed the AI was speeding them up. Like if you surveyed them, they reported feeling highly productive and efficient. But the objective stopwatch measurements proved they were actually measurably slower when using the AI.
How does that even happen? How do you feel faster while objectively losing time? It is the illusion of productivity. When a developer types a prompt and the AI instantly spits out 50 lines of code, it feels like massive forward momentum. You just save 10 minutes of
typing. Right. That makes sense. But what the developer doesn't mentally account for is the hour they spend later hunting down a subtle, silent logic error the AI introduced. Oh, wow. Yeah. We categorize typing as work, but we categorize debugging as a
frustrating roadblock. So our internal metronome just gets warped.
Think about what that Becker finding does to Anthropic's shiny new R&D automation index. If Claude is judging automation based on human Slack messages, and we now know humans suffer from an illusion of AI productivity, the foundation of those ratings might be totally flawed.
Built on sand, exactly.
If Anthropic's method is a fitness tracker, where users manually type in how fast they felt they ran, the Becker study tells us people think they are sprinting when they are actually just jogging.
That is the pivotal flaw of relying on self-reported internal records. And it's exactly why external researchers advocate for adversarial alternatives like our bench.
Which was created by Wick and colleagues, right?
Yes. RBench is like forcing those runners to get on a treadmill with a calibrated stopwatch. It doesn't ask humans how they felt.
What does it do instead?
It evaluates AI capability on fixed, handcrafted R&D tasks against actual human experts over grueling 8 to 32 hour time horizons.
Let's put them head to head. RBench versus the Anthropic Index. What are the blind spots of each design?
Well, they are almost mirror opposites. Anthropics Index captures the messy reality of daily work, but because it relies on internal records, it completely misses the objective performance degradation we saw in the Becker study.
It's blind to the illusion of speed.
Exactly. Our bench, on the other hand, is perfectly objective, but because its tasks are cleanly defined in a sterile environment, it misses the chaos of real-world coordination.
like confusing slack threads and undocumented legacy code.
Right. Anthropic trusts the messy humans too much, but our bench removes the human element entirely.
Which means neither gives a regulator the full picture. But, you know, for the sake of argument, let's say Anthropic is generally accurate and AI really is leading 26% of their R&D work. If I'm an engineer, I'm terrified of what an agent is doing while I'm not looking.
If they're operating that independently, how is Anthropic keeping them from going rogue or accidentally writing a massive security vulnerability into the next model?
Yeah. The stakes rise exponentially as work moves from collaborating to leading. And this brings us to their second set of metrics, which is oversight.
Right. Oversight. How are they tracking this?
Anthropic tracks this using what they call online and offline monitors. So in August 2026, their research and engineering agents made over one billion decisions.
One billion decisions in a single month.
Yes. And their online monitor, which is the system that checks actions in real time before they execute, blocked only 0.002% of those
actions. 0.002%. What is that in real numbers?
That breaks down to about 1 in 47,000 decisions.
1 in 47,000. I mean, if you have a billion people walking through a security checkpoint and the guard only stops one person out of every 47,000, is it because we live in a perfect utopia with absolutely no crime or is the security guard asleep in the booth?
That is the multibillion-dollar question in the safety community right now, and the architecture gets even more opaque when you look at their offline monitor.
What does the offline monitor do?
It reads the transcripts of what the agents did after the fact, looking for slower, more complex misalignments that a real-time filter might miss. Anthropic says that offline monitor flagged roughly 100,000 transcripts a week.
Okay, 100,000 flags out of a billion decisions feels a little more realistic.
But here is the bottleneck. They use automated filtering models to review those 100,000 flags. And after that automated AI review, only about 50 transcripts actually reached a human reviewer's desk.
Wait, you're telling me an AI filter reduces 100,000 potentially dangerous actions down to just 50 for a human to look at?
Yeah.
How does that filtering actually work mechanically?
To understand the mechanics, we have to look at the research by Korbach and colleagues on chain of thought monitorability.
What's the core theory there?
Modern AI models essentially think out loud before they act. They generate a text-based chain of thought, like a step-by-step logic puzzle, before executing a command. Korbeck points out that this gives us a unique opportunity to monitor
their inner monologue for malicious intent.
By having another AI read that text.
Right. It's
like being able to read the suspect's diary before they commit the crime.
Precisely. The filtering models are reading those diaries, looking for semantic red flags and stripping away false positives. But Korback's research highlights a severe warning.
Which is?
This opportunity is incredibly fragile. AI models can be deceptively aligned. They might not explicitly state a malicious intent in their chain of thought.
They might just hallucinate a harmless justification.
Exactly. Or the monitor itself might simply fail to recognize the subtlety of the threat.
So we have to ask the hard question here. Is a real-time block rate of 1 in 47,000 evidence that Anthropix agents are incredibly safe? Or does Corbix's warning suggest that the automated monitor just, well, fundamentally agrees
with the agent it is watching and is completely blind to subtle misbehaviors?
Given the fragility of chain of thought monitoring, it is highly probable that the monitor is missing things. Relying on an automated filter to reduce 100,000 flags down to 50 requires a staggering amount of trust in the competence of that filter.
If the monitor suffers from the same blind spots as the agent, that 0.002% block rate is basically a false comfort.
Absolutely.
Okay, so we've looked at R&D automation and we've looked at behavioral oversight. Both of these metrics rely entirely on AI models evaluating other AI models.
Yep.
The final way Anthropic tries to prove they're operating responsibly is by showing us where they spend their most valuable resource, which is compute power.
Yes, compute.
But just like the oversight metric, the compute numbers hide a massive paradox.
Compute is often viewed as the ultimate lie detector in AI development, right? You can massage survey data, but you can't fake a GPU burning electricity.
Right. So what did Anthropic measure?
They measured a snapshot week in July 2026, and they report that about 6% of the compute dedicated to overall AI R&D went specifically to safety work.
Okay, thanks a lot.
And if you zoom in on just the compute used for AI-driven AI R&D, meaning the models running those automated tasks we talked about earlier, about 12% was dedicated to
safety. 6% overall, 12% for the AI agents. It gives regulators a hard number. But there is a massive caveat that Anthropic freely admits to here. We can call it the safety compute paradox. Walk us through how efficiency actually punishes this metric.
It is a fascinating mechanical flaw. Imagine Anthropic safety engineers have a brilliant breakthrough. They build a highly efficient, lightweight safety classifier that does the exact same level of rigorous checking, but requires significantly less computing power to run.
Because it's efficient, it burns less electricity. So that safety percentage drops from 6% down to, say, 3%.
Exactly. On paper, to an outside observer, it looks like Anthropic just slashed their safety budget by half. It looks like they're acting less responsibly, even though the actual functional amount of safety work hasn't decreased at all.
They are just doing it better. Yes. Measuring safety by how much compute it burns is like measuring how safe a car is by how heavy the brake pads are. If you invent better brakes made of lighter carbon fiber, you look less safe on a spreadsheet.
It completely punishes engineering efficiency.
It really does. But honestly, this brings up the most glaring issue of this entire deep dive. Every single number we have discussed today is entirely self-reported. Which brings us to our final background source, the Foundation Model Transparency Index by Bamasani, Kleiman, and
colleagues.
Yeah, the Transparency Index provides vital historical context here. It set the precedent for scoring AI labs from the outside.
And what's their recurring finding?
Their loudest finding across the entire industry is that a lab's self-reported transparency is often vastly different from verified, actionable transparency.
So saying you're safe isn't the same as proving it to a third party.
Exactly. Historically, companies score the worst on what we call upstream indicators, things like raw training data, hardware usage, and unredacted compute logs when they are evaluated by independent outsiders.
Because graded homework means nothing without a teacher. Anthropic states in this document that they eventually plan to embed third-party evaluators to verify these practices. But right now, today, this 6% compute stat, the 26% automation index, the 1
in 47,000 block rate, this is all just Anthropic grading Anthropic.
The Transparency Index demands external verification because corporate incentives will always naturally lean toward presenting the best possible narrative. Of
course.
Without deep API access, without the raw, unredacted slack data, and without non-clawed external judges, a third party simply cannot reproduce any of these measurements.
So let's synthesize this. If you are a regulator listening to this or an outside researcher, what can you actually do with an R&D automation index of 26%, an oversight block rate of 0.002%, and a safety compute
share of 6%? Like, can a self-published index ever be used as a binding governance instrument?
In its current form, absolutely not. Right now, it establishes a vocabulary. It is a conversational starting point. But for this to become binding, a regulator would need technical infrastructure that just does not exist today.
What would they need?
They would need real-time external auditing of that frozen tree of tasks. They would need adversarial tests like rebench integrated directly into the daily workflow to combat the human illusions of productivity we saw in the Becker study. They would need unredacted compute logs.
They need to ensure the automated security guard isn't just rubber stamping the suspect's diary.
Exactly. Until those structural changes happen, these numbers are a fascinating window into a frontier lab, but they cannot be the anchor for public trust.
We spent this whole deep dive asking if we can trust an AI company grading itself with its own AI. But here is a final provocative thought for you to mull over as you go about your day. As that 26% automation number creeps toward 50%
or 80%, will humans even possess the technical context required to understand the Slack messages the AI is sending to itself?
That is a terrifying thought.
At what point does the measurement become untrustworthy, not just because of corporate bias, but because we simply cannot read the AI's handwriting anymore? You might finally get that perfect, fully automated performance review, only to realize you lack the intelligence to understand what it actually says.
Thanks for joining us on this deep dive. See you next time.